man what a click bait title right why is
elden ring dying which is definitely a
bold claim coming from a guy whose
channel is almost completely based on
elden ring and uncovering the incredibly
complicated story behind it but if we
look at the steam charts and the google
trends for eldon rings player base and
overall interest in the game it's
definitely started to take a huge dive
so today we're going to talk about why
that's the case because in my opinion it
isn't that the game is actually dying we
are all just probably a bit burnt out
from the game we all just kind of beat
the game right or most of us did anyway
see i play elden ring for multiple hours
every single day because it's my job now
i'm trying to learn everything that
there is about this game and because of
its massive size and complicated story
that's a giant endeavor that requires me
to play it every single day but for me
that's a dream job so i definitely don't
mind it i absolutely love it but for the
rest of the player base who i'm assuming
can't play video games every day all day
because they have school or work or
other life responsibilities don't really
want to play elden ring after they've
beat it that one time now this is sort
of strange because these players have
probably booted up other online
multiplayer games like valorant call of
duty apex legends fortnite whatever it
may be and they play it every day at
least for a little while but with eldon
ring they may not do that and why is
that because elden ring is mainly a
single player experience that during our
first or second playthrough of the game
might possibly be the best experience in
all of gaming that first playthrough is
just filled with incredible moments that
i'm going to remember for the rest of my
life and even during my second
playthrough i was finding out new things
about the game every single time i
played it because there's just so much
to discover there's so much content to
consume that it's somewhat overwhelming
at times that could be a part of another
issue that i'll talk about in a bit but
for now i believe the main issue is that
you aren't going to get that amazing
first playthrough experience ever again
once you sort of know where every boss
is where every item location is every
secret discovery you may find that
feeling of discovery and exploration
fade away which is what open world games
are for they are meant for you to
explore a giant open world and discover
for yourself all of the amazing things
that there are to find but once you've
found everything which mind you takes
hundreds of hours in the world of elden
ring to fully complete then there really
isn't much more to do after that once
you've played all of the content that
there is to offer and once you're out of
content you're going to move on to the
next thing more likely than not but why
isn't this the case with the multiplayer
games that i mentioned earlier because
the experience of competing against
other players is most of the time a
completely different experience every
time you enter a match there are
different players maps weapons to use
things like that that make the
experience different every time you play
it whereas with elden ring the field of
play doesn't really change ever once
you've discovered those areas and beaten
those bosses you know what to expect
they even use the same movements against
you which is fun to perfect and beat
bosses without having much trouble
eventually once you get good enough
that's why there's such a big interest
in modded playthroughs or challenge runs
of souls games it really mixes up the
formula to make the game or the
challenge different and interesting from
what we are used to and obviously in
elden ring you can make different builds
to give yourself a slightly different
experience but when i'm talking about
the field of play meaning the map and
the bosses and things to discover you're
only gonna get that really one or two
times or one or two playthroughs and you
might be asking but jake eldon ring does
have multiplayer and you'd be right
there is a ton of potential for elden
ring in regards to pvp there's so many
different build types weapons spells
buffs incantations that can make every
invasion or duel a truly different
experience every time not to mention the
endless amount of locations where you
can fight and duel and just completely
change the setting of that unfortunately
from my understanding the pvp community
for elden ring is in a pretty tough spot
right now now i'm not a pvp player
myself but i've been paying attention to
those who are and what they think
because i understand the major
importance of multiplayer in regards to
a game's longevity and continued
interest over time especially with a
game that i love to death like elden
ring and from what i've heard there's
some serious issues with certain weapons
in pvp that are just completely
unbalanced obviously when a weapon or a
spell or whatever it is is overpowered
and gives the player the best chance at
success of beating their opponent they
are going to use that weapon 9 times out
of 10. this is the case with almost
every multiplayer game out there i used
to play a lot of warzone and most of the
time there would be a particular meta
where the entire player base only used
one type of gun because it was seen as
the best gun to use and to win the game
most of the time the developers would
see that weapons usage was much higher
than other weapons and they just nerfed
that weapon into the ground so it
wouldn't be used as much now i
definitely don't think this is the best
way to handle it because we all remember
what happened to horfrost stomp it was
used by quite literally everybody
because it was so powerful and then they
nerfed it into nothingness and it isn't
even used in pve anymore there is a
needed balance that i'm sure is
extremely difficult to hit in all of
these games especially with elden ring
when there are so many different weapons
and abilities that need to somehow be
balanced together there's also the issue
of certain players not fully
understanding how pvp works in from
software games in elden ring apparently
there's a stigma against invasions where
a player can invade another player's
world during their playthrough to try
and kill them and this has been an
aspect and a feature of from software's
game design for forever at this point
invasions are not a new thing however
with elden rings worldwide success there
are a lot of new players who quite
frankly don't understand how pvp works
and just see invasions as a way to annoy
or ruin a player's playthrough by
randomly entering their world and just
killing them yeah it's the invader's
goal to invade your world and kill you
but it isn't to completely ruin your
playthrough if you die all you lose is a
slight bit of progression from the last
sight of grace and the runes that you
can more than likely get back with no
problem at all it's an exciting aspect
of the game to not know when you're
going to be invaded or where you will be
invaded it keeps the player on their
toes at all times and is obviously very
enjoyable for the invader to pull off a
kill since they get certain rewards for
successfully killing the host of that
world they invaded unfortunately the new
player base has sort of stigmatized
invasions as nothing more than pure
annoyance and it has gotten to the point
where everyone has just turned their
games offline and don't even bother with
the online aspects of the game doing
this reduces the amount of players
co-opting with their friends and then in
turn reduces the amount of invadable
worlds for the players who do want to
participate in the pvp eventually that
offline player will beat everything in
the game and they will just stop playing
the game all together same goes to the
pvper who will likely stop playing the
game because they can never find a world
to invade and participate in the
multiplayer both sides of the spectrum
people who like and don't like pvp are
sort of shooting themselves in the foot
essentially now i believe all of this
will be addressed soon because why else
would from software design these
coliseums that we cannot currently enter
that are spread all over the world if
they weren't going to be used for either
pve boss fights and maybe a boss rush
mod or a perfect area for pvp from
software definitely needs to get on this
issue if they do want their player base
to go back up they are more than likely
working on the first dlc for elden ring
right now which i'm sure will revitalize
the player base to come back and get
that next new experience like we were
talking about earlier again this is a
big reason multiplayer games hold their
player bases for long periods of time
they are constantly pushing out updates
that can keep their player base playing
and interested new content will always
bring players back with elden ring the
game was and is so incredibly good that
all of those players that are currently
burnt out on the game will likely come
back as soon as new content is released
you could even argue that players will
be even more excited for new elden ring
content compared to other games because
while they don't release new content all
that often and again the game is so good
on its own already that there isn't any
type of stain on the game for it not
releasing new updates or new content
more often we got such a high quality
experience with the main release of
elden ring then i am more than happy to
wait for new updates to release and new
content to come out if it matches that
high quality experience there was a
massive amount of content that we
consumed at launch but four months is
more than enough time for most players
to have beaten most stuff in the game
and have just moved on to something else
another small thing i'd like to bring up
that may only be a case for myself and
if you feel the same way let me know but
i don't like making new characters in
elden ring i like having my first
character that i started out with in my
first playthrough and getting that
character as strong as possible i enjoy
going from struggling in my first
playthrough to completely destroying
bosses in new game plus it makes me feel
like my character and i have gone
through all of this adversity together
and have overcome it together as well as
soon as i make a new character i feel
like i abandoned my previous character
it's kind of a weird feeling it's also
not super inviting to go from that
overpowered state that you work so hard
to achieve back down to where it all
started in this super weak state the
sheer size and scope of doing all of
that again with a completely new
character is overwhelming and somewhat
daunting of a task that i guarantee a
lot of players will just pass on now
this video may really seem like i'm
talking negatively about the game but i
really don't think eldon ring is dying
whatsoever the player base might be
lower but like i said all of those
players are going to come back as soon
as new content releases it's clearly
been a major success and i'm happy to
see from software finally get the
mainstream exposure i've always thought
their games deserved but when something
goes mainstream there's definitely going
to be side effects like we talked about
elden ring is one of the best games i've
ever played is it my favorite souls game
my opinion has kind of changed on that
the more i've played the game it's just
a totally different experience from
let's say bloodborne to elden ring they
are two totally different things that i
think stack up right next to each other
in quality of what the game is designed
for and i think that's because along
with a major part of the player base is
that we've all displayed everything that
there is to offer with elden ring and
we're all just a bit burnt out for now
but what do you guys think let me know
down in the comments and also let me
know if you'd like to see more
commentary videos like this i used to do
these kinds of videos all the time on a
previous channel i love talking and
discussing all things gaming with my
community doesn't have to be just souls
games so hopefully you would like that
as well let me know down below have a
great rest of your day and i will see
you all in the next one take care